okay we're live good afternoon cs109 how
are you guys doing today
let's try that again it's a Friday how
are you guys doing yay
um I appreciate like you know what are
we week four I think we're week four
it's like a little bit harder to like
midterms are coming around the corner
speaking of which we have our midterms
not next week but the week after in
cs109 and the one big announcement for
that is please do fill up that form to
let us know if you're going to take it
on a Tuesday or Wednesday we need to
make sure that we have enough seats uh
and that will depend on how many people
are showing up on each day so you're
doing us a huge favor so absolutely if
you could please fill out that form
um and we have a wonderful class today
we're going to be learning about
inference how we're going to change our
beliefs in the face of new information
what an incredibly important thing to
know how to do uh with random variables
and we're going to learn how to do it
today uh it's a Friday
so I thought I would tell you guys a
story let's see I told you guys the
story of how my parents met
amazing
and normally I save this for the end of
the quarter but I was going to start
telling you guys about how I met my wife
because I love Laura stories so um you
know well I'll tell you guys a little
about this and it's kind of interesting
because you know I'd like to tell you
about stories that have taken place
since then so I met my wife not during
my co-term year but the year after my
co-term so I did a co-term at Stanford
and then after I finished my co-turner
I'm like I'm done I'm out of here I took
a entire year off I got into a PhD
program I was like don't call me for you
know 365 days and in that time I went
back to Kenya which was lovely and I
spent a few months there and at some
point I decided I had this great idea I
was like in a whole year I was going to
slowly make my way back to campus and so
I started traveling and I made it all
the way to Greece
but it was 2011 and there was a economic
crisis in Greece and I was on a ferry
and the ferry conductor says wherever
you get off you're not leaving because
there's not going to be a ferry for
several weeks uh so I chose an island
and uh it turns out that my wife to be
also got stuck on the same island for
similar reasons uh and because there is
no way on or off it was a small island
we kept running into each other like we
just met each other I was sitting on a
wall and she's like it's a nice view and
I'm like yeah and we had the most
wonderful two-minute conversation
but then the person I was waiting for
came and we're supposed to go for a walk
and then my wife now wife was like can I
come with you and the person who I met
was like no
that could have been the end of the
story but since we're stuck on the same
island we saw each other uh a few times
and like we were running each other and
be like hey I remember you
um
but then one day the strikes ended the
there was ways off the islands and we
went different directions and I
genuinely thought I would never see this
person again
until a few days later I'd made my way
to Athens I got a message and it says hi
Chris you know I was thinking about it
it's really nice to meet you I'm going
to be in Northern Romania in like three
days come join or two days and I was
like oh that sounds really exciting but
there's no way I can cross so much of
Europe in just two days
um I couldn't afford the flight because
I didn't have that much money I couldn't
afford a train and a bus was too slow to
get me there in time and that could have
been the end of the story but somebody
this is a bad idea don't do this at home
convince me that hitchhiking was a
reasonable thing and they sent me to
like athenshitchhiking.com where I had
like step-by-step instructions on how to
do it it's like you get a sign and you
stick your thumb up and they tell you
where to go and I went there and nothing
three hours just standing on the side of
a highway and be like what am I doing
with my life
um but then at some point a motorcyclist
took me a little bit further and then a
car took me a little bit further and
then another car took me a little bit
further and I was really stuck in the
middle of nowhere and now when I was
there for three hours like this could be
dangerous um but as a rest stop and a
truck pulled in and he went to sleep and
three hours later when the truck driver
woke up I put my little sign up and he
opened his door and he said come on in
and he gave me a long ride and the most
wonderful thing happened it was like a
eight hour ride and I fell asleep which
I could have died but instead of dying
he woke me up he was like Chris while
you're asleep I called all my friends
and I told them the story I told him I
was gonna go meet this girl I met which
he liked uh and he said I told all my
friends and tonight you're going to come
to my house we'll feed you we'll give
you clothes or it'll clean her clothes
I'm like hey I'm pretty clean but um and
then we'll get to all my friends are
gonna pitched together we buy a flight
so you can make it there on time and
this is a stranger who's already doing a
nice thing for me in the moment of a
crisis like he must have felt some fear
for what this Christ is going to mean
for him 2011 was a pretty serious crisis
for Greece and he was just so generous
and it's hard to name something that was
so generous in my life of course I said
no though because even though I didn't
have very much money that was too much
for me to accept so what he did instead
is he snuck 20 euros into my backpack
but more importantly he set me up with
his friends so like when I got off
another friend took me and then they
would call ahead and I got like a chain
of four trucks that got me all the way
to Northern Romania and I remember like
like 22 years old and I walk across into
Bulgaria in the middle of night in like
late October around this time of year
and this truck pulls up it's like are
you Chris I'm like yes it's like are you
gonna go me like yeah that's me and I
just got in this person's truck
um anyways I'll tell you the rest of the
story over uh over another Friday but um
we'll leave that as a little bit of
suspense for now
um but we know how it ends
um but the details are worth recounting
also worth recounting is today's topic
we're going to learn such a crazy cool
idea I split this amazing idea into two
lectures and I did restructure cs109 a
little bit because when I thought about
I was like this is one of those 10 out
of 10 things you really really want to
know deep in your veins when you walk
out of cs109 so I slowed down a little
bit so I can give you guys this pretty
hard idea in two different lectures so
you guys are going to be putting on your
pretty hard thinking hats today and
we're gonna see if we can work through
this idea of inference and inference is
a very formal name for if you see
evidence how do you change your pmf or
your PDF of a random variable not just
your belief in an event but the entire
PDF and that's what we call inference
fancy name for right relatively
straightforward concept and as always
I've gotten in the habit this is the
first chord I've really done this of
putting all the questions for the
lectures uh into the pset app and you
can find them on the course website but
by this point of course you probably
know that
where are we we're in the part of the
class where we're talking about multiple
random variables being random together
and particularly I want to give you an
idea of where are we locally and what
are we going to do in the world of
probabilistic models
first we introduce the concept of many
random many variables being random
together through the world of discrete
models so many random variables that can
just take on discrete values themselves
we learn about joints in particular
joint probability tables and then we
were introduced to our first
joint model called the multinomial
today we're going to learn inference an
inference is the task of how do you
change a random variable's belief in a
probabilistic model when you see
observations but the other tasks that
you're going to learn in the sections
we're going to do a little bit of
modeling how could you create your own
probabilistic model and then finally I'm
going to teach you a really cool
randomized algorithm that you can use
for solving inference problems for any
probabilistic model so that's our
journey and it starts well on Wednesday
and it continues with inference today
some learning goals we're going to
continue our conversation about the
multinomial I hope by the end of today's
class you really appreciate the utility
of log probabilities and then finally
we're going to really focus on improving
your ability to combine Bayes theorem
with random variables two grade tastes
that taste great together
there are a few things we're going to
use today
and here's one of them that you probably
haven't seen and you probably haven't
thought of because it seems nonsensical
you wouldn't really use it in a
probability problem but sometimes it
shows up in proofs
recall when you have a continuous random
variable one of the ways of representing
it is using this probability density
function like this could be the probably
density function of let's say an
exponential random variable
and an exponential random variable take
on continuous values
we don't really think about the
probability of it taking on one specific
value as having too much meaning right
like what's the probability that the
height of a baby is four pounds .000
like to infinite precision
it doesn't have meaning because all
babies will be slightly different than
that number no baby will be exactly
equal to infinite precision
that still holds true yet there is this
one calculus intuition that I want to
remind you of because we're going to use
it in some proofs
if you ask about the probability of a
baby being 4 to infinite Precision zeros
doesn't make sense but if you allow for
a range of values you say like 4 plus or
minus point zero one that does make
sense you can say what's the probability
that a baby is in that range does that
make sense
so if you have a range you get a
probability
and so sometimes we think about the
smallest Range possible
and we call this the Epsilon range if
you haven't seen Epsilon before we use
it in mathematics to represent the
smallest number possible so the limit of
a number as it goes towards zero
so you can take a density and multiply
it by this Epsilon and you know that is
one very calculusy way to think about
the probability that a continuous random
variable takes on a value
I'm just going to plant this seed in
your mind we're going to use it again
later and then we'll revisit it but I
just want to start that idea germinating
to show you how you might use that
particular idea here's an interesting
question
I'm going to say the time to finish a
problem set is given by a gaussian
recall that a gaussian is a continuous
random variable so if this is a gaussian
for how long it takes to finish problem
set three you could think about what's
the probability density at say 10 hours
or the probability density at five hours
the question I'd like to think about is
how much more likely are you to complete
in 10 hours than in five hours
at first blush you might think this is
nonsensical because it's
probability zero that you finish in
exactly 10 hours and probability zero
that you finish in exactly five hours
but it turns out to the Limit this zero
is zero could be interpreted differently
to give it some meaning
you could say actually I do think it's
more likely to finish in 10 hours and
five hours you know if you look at the
gaussian at 10 hours the PDF is much
higher than at five hours
so how could we make sense of this
statement in light of our idea that
probability of x equals 10 is probably a
zero number and probably x equals five
is also a zero number
well to better understand this we can
use that Epsilon trick that we just
talked about we can say this probably
the x equals 10 is actually the density
at 10 times by some really tiny range
I'm not going to specify how tying the
range is but I wrote one that's really
really small
and I can do the same thing take the
density at five so five hours to finish
your problem set and multiply it by the
same width tiny tiny range
these epsilons are totally problematic
if they end up in the end of your answer
there's nothing you can do with this is
polluted your answer but they're helpful
when they cancel
and as you can see here by putting this
Epsilon range on the top and putting
this Epsilon range on the bottom I got
meaningful statements
these eplons are like infinitely small
numbers but they exactly cancel each
other out which leads us to this
question which is hard to think about is
actually equal to just the ratio of the
probability densities
that feels intuitive it's saying the
ratio of the probability density at 10
to 5 tells us how much more likely you
are to complete at 10 hours than 5 hours
and at this point we're going to use
this beautiful equation that we've
talked a lot about but haven't used yet
this is the normal probability density
function looks rather scary but it's
just a beautiful probability density
function equation and I'm just plugging
in 10 and we can use mu and the variance
we can plug in those numbers too and
eventually once you plug in all those
numbers you end up with a reduction that
goes you know e to the power of 0
divided by e to the negative 25 over 4
which is a 518.
so we can give a semantic answer to how
much more likely are you to complete a
problem set in 10 hours than in five is
that a mind-blowing way to start a
Friday or what so you know the the long
story short there is this trick you can
use when you talk about the probability
of a continuous random variable equaling
a number you can either think of that as
just being zero or you can think about
it as the density times by the tiniest
range possible
questions comments concerns arguments
anyone have something they want to ask
about this
yes what is the 500 agent represent
again it's saying this 518 is the ratio
of these so it's saying you're 518 times
more likely to finish it in 10 hours
than in five hours so it gives you some
idea that like this is this is much more
likely according to this gaussian
um
it's certainly not a probability it's a
ratio of probabilities it's saying you
know how much bigger is this probability
than that probability some people will
call that an odds but we can talk about
that another day
I thought in the past that probably like
the probability that X is something like
the PMS like yeah which is like probably
x equals 10 is equal to pmf x equals
okay good good question what you said is
completely correct in the discrete case
so if x is a discrete random variable
like a binomial how many coin how many
heads do I get those are countable it's
discrete it can be one two three and if
you want to know the probability that x
equals 10 you just look up in the
probability Mass function 100 correct in
the continuous case though it's not just
the probability Mass function you can
think of it as being very similar to
probably density function that's really
what's happening here we're just using
the ratio of the probability density
functions but probably densities are not
probabilities
and I just wanted to talk about that so
in a continuous case when you say x
equals 10 it's a much more complicated
claim than saying a discrete thing is
takes on the value 10.
because in math continuous things have
infinite precision
okay as I said this is just a warm up to
an idea I want to let it germinate a
little bit and we'll come back to this
later when we talk about inference
we also talked about when random
variables are random together
so we when introduce ourselves to this
concept on Wednesday and we thought
about random variables being random
together and we had this fun little
example of two random variables one
random variable which is what year are
you at Stanford and the other random
variable represents well in this case I
think we oh yeah we talked about uh
relationship status last time but here's
a new data for some excitement this is
what is the room situation and this was
collected a few years ago in cs109
anonymously
and so this
if you have these two random variables
the be all endle the most useful thing
you can have is what we call a joint
distribution which says I have a way of
telling the probability of any joint
assignment to each of my random
variables so what's the probability that
year is junior and two room double
equals or the end the room type equals
two room double
if you added up all these probabilities
they should be one if you add up any row
you marginalize out the rooms and you're
left with just the probability of the
year so this is probably freshman
sophomore junior senior uh five plus and
if you sum up the columns you
marginalize out the year and you're just
left with the probability of somebody
having roommates two room doubles a
shared partner or a single
okay A little bit of review
joint distribution if you have a
probabilistic model if you have more
than one random variable this is the
thing you really care about it's the
probability Mass function equivalent for
multiple random variables and it's where
you give me a statement which says
what's the probability of this
particular assignment to my first random
variable and this particular assignment
to other random variable remember this
comma means and
if you have more than two random
variables you know you want to have a
expression that can tell you the
likelihood of all those assignments
happening at the same time this joint
distribution is important because if
somebody gives me the joint I can
calculate any probability question
anyone could ever want to know about my
model
notation I just want to talk about it
for a second hey new slides are a little
bit slower on here than on my computer
there you go notation
I don't want to lose anybody on this but
this shorthand becomes so common when
you have multiple random variables that
you need to know it I will often try and
use the top notation when I can but
often that's not possible if there's
lots of random variables
the top expression says exactly what I
want what's the probability that this
random variable equals this number and
this other random variable equals the
second number little Y where the little
numbers the little y's represent that I
expect you to put non-random values in
there
that takes up too much space so some
people write it like this and then other
people are like you know the capital x
kind of implies the lowercase x and the
capital Y implies the lowercase y so
it's a bit redundant what if we just
wrote this and everyone can just know
then we write this we mean that and it's
like what
this is like talking about the
probability of constants what are you
doing but that's the notation people
often use so if you see a probability
like this just know that it's implying a
full probability statement that has
proper events
and the proper events are quality events
and the implied random variables are the
capitals of what you see
mind-blowing okay
anyways joints they're really important
we had this problem though we would
start to represent probabilistic models
with joint tables and that was a good
time until we started until we started
putting a couple random variables
together and once you had more than two
random variables we realized that the
size of your joint table would grow
exponentially
and that's a problem for representing a
computer it's also a problem for the
scientists who are trying to come up
with the probability values
so our solution was are there ways we
can model the world so that you can
represent a joint
without having to write a full uh
probability or a joint probability table
welcome the multinomial multinomial
answered the question if I were to roll
n dice where each dice has M different
outcomes what's the probability of
seeing C1 outcomes of type 1 C2 outcomes
of type 2 and CM outcomes of Type M
this is naturally a probabilistic model
because there are naturally multiple
random variables that are be random
together how many outcomes of type one
how many outcomes of type 2 to how many
outcomes of Type M if it's a dice
there's six outcomes and the probability
of each outcome is one over six but the
multinomial can be more General you can
have more than six outcomes and you can
specify the probability of each outcome
similar to the binomial distribution a
similar derivation leads to this
beautiful equation where this is a
constant it's a n choose C1 C2 CM which
is same as n factorial divided by this
factorial this factorial this factorial
so that's a big old number multiplied by
probability of outcome one
to the power of how many times you saw
outcome one
this would let you do silly things with
dice with like saying if I roll seven
dice what's it probably is seeing six
ones and a two and zero of the other
outcomes
but allows us to do more interesting
things particularly we got into
probabilistic text analysis
probabilistic test analysis was could
model a document as a multinomial we'd
make a big dice which was the author's
probability of writing any particular
word so instead of having six sides it
has one side for every word the author
could write and the corresponding
probability of that side was the
probably the author would write that and
we imagine the creation of a document as
the author just getting out their
massive dice rolling it seeing which
word came out writing it and rolling
again seeing which word came out writing
it down and that's how the author
produced the document
if you imagine that's how we get counts
of words in a document then it means
that you can think about those counts of
words using exactly the multinomial
end of review that was a long way to get
to the punch line that we all wanted to
get to
who wrote The Federalist Papers so on
Wednesday's class we started writing
this program to figure out did Alexander
Hamilton or Madison write Federalist
paper 53. I gave you data I gave you
samples of Madison's writing I gave you
samples of Hamilton's writing from those
things you could calculate these two
probabilities for every word I you can
calculate the probability that Hamilton
writes that word it's just how many
times it shows up in the sample divided
by a number of words
and same thing with Madison for any word
I or I could be like the or Congress or
you know Chris he doesn't write Chris
that's sad uh Mi would be the
probability of Madison writing word I
these two documents allow you to get h i
and MI
and this document is the Federalist
paper we care about and that Federalist
paper we can count how many times each
word I appears and we're going to call
those CIS
and we decide we're going to use Bayes
theorem we're going to say we have
counts of words we know the probability
of different authors writing different
words
uh can we figure out who wrote this
document and we said we can think of it
like this
if I knew Hamilton was the author it's
easy to think about the probability of
the counts of words that's just a
multinomial
this is a hard probability but we can
calculate using Bayes theorem using this
easier one it requires us to know
probably H and probably of t
probably of H is How likely do we think
Hamilton is to write this if we had no
other information and we're just saying
that's one half
um and then probably if D was a problem
this thing on the bottom we call it the
normalization constant it's a problem a
lot of the time so we have lots of
tricks to deal with it
the particular oh and just you know want
to point out that that's a multinomial
and we want to figure out what to do
with this
the particular trick we wrote we used
you can either see the slides or I wrote
it over here
is I want to get rid of the probability
of D I didn't want to calculate it
so I use this super crafty trick use it
learn it show your friends
probably if Hamilton given D is this
expression
and the probability of Madison given D
is the same expression and both of them
have this probability of d
and the super tricky ones out there
might realize if you took this term and
divide by this term we could make those
probabilities of D's just go away
so you don't have to ever calculate it
probably if D is a weird thing we call
it the normalization constant because
it's a weird thing and saying like
what's the probability of seeing these
words without conditioning on who the
author is and it's really hard to think
about the processing these words if you
don't know who the author is in both
this term and M given or D given M we
know who the author is we've been told
Hamilton Madison are the authors
but if we write this out check out what
happens
this term is divided by D and this term
is divided by D so these two things just
cancel out ah what a good time and it
gets even better we assume that before
we see anything any data the probability
of Hamilton is one half and the probably
of Madison is one half
so these two terms just cancel out ah
what good times and you're like does it
get any better I tell you it gets even
better why is it get even better this
coefficient has to do with the counts of
the words in the documents you know C1
is how many times word one shows up in
the unknown document and so is this C1
in fact these two terms are exactly the
same because they're both just an
expression of the counts of the words in
the exact same document so lo and behold
these two terms just go away wait I
forgot a product over here
that would be funny
it's we're going to Loop over all the
words in the document
for every word we're going to say what's
the probability that Hamilton wrote that
word and we're going to raise it to the
power of how many times the word shows
up
and this term is for every word in the
document figure out the probability that
Madison wrote the word and then raise it
to the probability or the count of the
time or times that it shows up
this led to this wonderful piece of code
where
you know I do some pre-processing on the
text
and I calculate Hamilton word
probabilities those are all the H I's
I calculate Madison word probabilities
those are all the Mis and I show you a
lookup I look up Congress so it's like
where I is Congress I look up Hamilton
word probability mass and word probably
and the counts
and then I calculate this term passing
in the Hamilton dictionary and then I
calculated this term passing in the
Madison dictionary so here is passing
the Hamilton dictionary that gives the
Hamilton term calculate with the Madison
dictionary that gives the medicine term
and then I print those out
this equation cheeky little bugger does
that
it starts with a probability of one y
one if you multiply anything times zero
you'll get zero so I start with a one
and I'm going to multiply these terms in
one at a time remember this is a for
Loop over products
so it's a for Loop if you haven't seen a
for Loop like this in Python it says
take your dictionary of count items and
give me one at a time which word was
written and how many times it shows up
I look up in the dictionary what's the
probability of the word I and I raise it
to the power of CI so I do this
computation
and I get a running product for
probabilities
it seems so beautiful look it's nicely
commented I use the snake case what a
good time to be alive and we feel so
good about ourselves
um until we run the code
h i where I is Congress is a number it's
a probability m i where I is Congress is
a number it's a probability c i where I
is Congress is a count it's how many
times the word Congress shows up
everything seems good except when we
calculate these probabilities they are
zero
what could go wrong now sometimes you
just look at code and you know it you're
like my soul speaks to me and I know
exactly what the bug is but other times
we debug maybe you see debugger or maybe
you did a print line so I'm like what's
going on here I'm going to print
like this for Loop
it's continually updating a probability
variable and I want to print out that
probability as we go and look at what
happens
scrolling up scrolling up that's a lot
of zeros
oh look
first iteration it's one second
iteration is pretty small third
iteration it's about as small as you can
imagine this says 2.5 times 10 to the
negative 309.
tiny and then after that your computer
is like I can't even I just can't even I
don't want to talk about numbers smaller
than 10 to the negative 309. what's
going on here
yeah what's wrong
[Music]
but this is where you just can't get
along
when you multiply these small numbers
together in theory it makes sense and
when you divide it you'll get a tiny
tiny number here like this is a small
number
multiplied by itself a bunch of times
multiplied by a whole bunch of other
small numbers this is
also teenage
teen and in theory dividing these two
teeny tiny numbers will give us our
answer but the computer doesn't want to
it can't represent numbers that small so
when you multiply probabilities against
each other especially small ones you
often get underflows which is why you
guys need to know about log
probabilities
log probabilities don't have too much
semantics except they're just taking the
log of a calculation why would you just
take a log of a calculation well you
might just end up with something that a
computer could represent
so for example if you told me the answer
not to this expression but log of this
expression
I would still be able to tell you who
wrote the document I'd be able to look
at this number and reason about whether
or not it was Hamilton or Madison if you
give me the log of this ratio
and the nice thing about this is then
you would do the log of these two sides
and when you do the log of these two
sides
you actually get something nice first
you get the log of this
minus the log of this instead of
division because divisions just become
subtraction and when you do the log of
this product it's like the log is a big
old tractor it's going to bulldoze right
through that product system and when it
bulldozes it just leaves you with a
beautiful sum and the log just goes
right inside as a tractor
the log of a product is the sum of logs
as you guys know
um so h i to the power of c i
minus the sum of the log
of m i to the power of CI
so that's what happens when you do a log
to this term
all those products becomes additions and
this division becomes a subtraction it's
a little bit better than that
you know the log of something raised to
a power
is just the log of that thing Times by
the power
and we have ourselves a very nice
expression so if you took the log of
this term
you can get something that you would
compute in a different way it's a lot of
additions of small numbers logs of small
numbers and hopefully it doesn't lead to
an underflow we're going to then get an
answer which isn't the ratio but rather
the log of the ratio we'll have to do a
little bit more work to interpret it so
let's go over to code that does that
exact same code
but instead of calculating the
probability I mean calculate the log
probability
so instead of starting with 1 I'm going
to start with the log of 1 and then I'm
going to do this sum
Loop over every word
get the probability of the word
do the log of that probability and
multiply it by how many times the word
shows up so a nice one two three four
five line program
if we do this we're going to get log
terms on the top and log terms on the
bottom who wants to see what happens
predict
what
[Music]
okay
back up Chris
okay um instead of talking the
probability of D given H we no longer
have zeros
we have these big negative numbers
and so the log of the probability of the
document given Hamilton is this negative
fourteen thousand and log of the
probably docking given Madison is this
negative thirteen thousand if you
subtract those two terms you'll get the
log of this ratio and if you subtracted
those two terms you get negative 1 353.
so this log of this
a ratio of probabilities is negative one
thousand three hundred about
who wrote the document
Madison
what how did they know it's Madison
okay how does that tell me the answer to
this
if it wasn't a log if Madison wrote this
let's say Madison was the actual author
if Madison was the actual author the
probably Madison given document should
be greater than probably Hamilton given
documents you guys agree so if Madison's
truly the author this should be a number
less than one because it's a smaller
number divided by a bigger number it
should be something like uh 0.2 or
something like that you know that would
be that Madison
um
is much more likely than Hamilton to
have written it
if this ratio if Hamilton wrote it then
this ratio should be greater than one
this number should be bigger
beautiful thing about logs that you need
to know can I tell you I would love to
tell you this beautiful thing about logs
okay A little bit of review
here's a graph of the log function
and notice at log of 1 something special
happens
if you put a number that's bigger than
one into a log you get a positive and if
you put a number between 0 and 1 into a
log you get a negative
so if you put in 0 Log of 0.2 you'll get
a negative number if you put in log of 5
you'll get a positive number
since this is a leg negative number I
know that this ratio must be less than
one let me just show you that really
quickly so that you believe me so python
import
math.log of say we put in a number
greater than one like three you get a
positive let's say we put in something
like 0.5 that's less than one you get a
negative
so anytime you see a negative expression
from a log you know that something less
than 1 1 in there which means I know
Madison wrote that
um and like if you put in a really small
number you get a larger negative if you
put in a really really small number you
get a much larger negative
this negative 13
000 like what do I have to put in here
to get the log to be thirteen thousand a
lot
our model is very very confident that
Madison Rose not like Madison Rose like
Madison definitely wrote this thing
Hamilton's a liar okay question
yeah
yes you can certainly take advantage of
the fact that
um you know log
base e of
some number so like K
is
saying that equals let's say n is the
same as claiming that e to the power of
n equals K you could take advantage of
this and turn and actually calculate
this exact number totally two reasonable
approaches
okay
now we know Madison wrote it can we take
a step back and think about what we were
supposed to have learned
so first of all we use the multinomial
to come up with this probability of the
document knowing who the author was it
used the counts of words a lot of things
canceled out and it led to a really nice
expression for How likely is a document
given the author
we use Bayes theorem with a multinomial
as a warm up to the idea that Bayes
theorem can show up in lots of places
and then you saw this super important
concept which is that in computer
science
if you're doing a probability that
involves a lot of products with small
numbers you might get underflow and your
solution to that is to use this thing
called a log probabilities just put a
log in front of it it's a different
representation of the concept you're
trying to calculate a lot of things and
one cool example and there's a question
in the back
um so I guess a lot of business and the
logifications for the information with
us but it's very um
succinctly I guess how the left hand
side of the board relates to the right
side of the board so the left board on
your left oh on this one yeah
so this is how you know a
straightforward way to figure out if
Hamilton wrote this document is to
calculate this expression
but this expression has this term which
is easy
this term which is Trivial and this term
which is insanely hard
now one thing we sometimes do
is we take this bottom term
and we turn it into the lobster probably
you do something like the probability of
D given h
times the probability of H
plus the probability of D given Madison
times the probability of Mass have
anyone ever done something like this
yes okay good
um you could have done this
but if you approach I gave you a
different way to get rid of the
probability of D which was I was going
to give you the ratio of Hamilton to
Madison can I tell you cheeky why I
didn't do it this way
if I tried to do it this way when I
apply my log
this will be straightforward this will
be straightforward and this addition
here is going to be a total disaster
because the log of a plus b doesn't turn
into a nice expression uh it becomes
quite hard to express you'd actually
have to calculate some of these
probabilities on their own it's really
really hard to simplify this expression
if you went straight to a log of this
probability like if you're trying to do
log
of Hamilton given document difficult
possible but difficult I use this trick
got rid of the D and then when I did the
log
everything was very nice because I
didn't have this awful summation in the
in the normalizing constant
so actually that is another big takeaway
is that this normalization constant
is a huge problem for Bayes theorem and
you now know two tricks for dealing with
it you can expand using log total
probability or you can do this ratio and
get it to cancel out
yes
just something different from technology
that probably Innovation probability of
um
yeah absolutely there's lots of you know
these priors your belief before you see
data it's a lot of Scholastic
argumentation be like I think that our
belief before we see data should be like
0.8 that is Hamilton because he wrote
more papers
um it turns out the the multinomial is
so convinced that even if you brought in
different priors it gets totally
overwhelmed by the evidence and it gets
washed out so it turns out it didn't
really matter what your prior belief was
unless you say like I'm 9999999 positive
it's Hamilton before you start your
calculations it's going to lead to
Madison being the author now it would
have been fine here you would have just
ended up with you know
log of this would have been plus log
of probability of H
and this would have been you know minus
this which is log of probability of
Madison like the all the calculations
would have worked out quite nicely
okay
fantastic which I feel like that
summarizes the mood at this moment it's
like yeah we can do it what a cool thing
to be able to do at this point in cs109
okay
I want to go back to a clay oh there's a
bunch of things where we want to be able
to do
um with
uh
with probabilistic models so now you can
kind of use a joint and I want us to get
to start thinking about conditional
probabilities with joint variables does
that sound good I want us to get a
little bit more formal about if you have
a model what does conditioning mean
this is inference it's one of the most
important things you can learn in the
whole field of probability inference
really says this conditional probability
is with joint variables in a model says
I have a model of how the world works I
observe from information and now my
model will change and thinking about how
your model will change when you
condition on things You observe that's
one of the be-alls and ends alls of why
we study this whole field so let's learn
how to do it and let's go back to our
friends who are living with roommates or
in two room doubles shared Partners
cs109 from years past
The Joint probability table tells you
everything you need to solve conditional
probability questions but let's go ahead
and try solving some of them so here's a
joint probability of what room peoples
were in and what year they were you guys
ready to go to the Internet let's go to
the internet
do do
okay
I have here
your joint table it says like what does
this cell mean this says like what's the
chance that somebody's both a junior and
has a roommate
I now want us to bump up our utility and
start using this joint to solve
conditional probability questions and
I'm going to challenge you guys with one
I'm going to challenge you with I'm
going to tell you the value of this
random variable
I'm going to tell you that this random
variable is equal to sophomore there or
actually let's do junior their year is a
junior so I tell you that their year is
a junior what's your new belief in their
room situation
and how could you calculate it if you
want to make this simpler just start
with one value if I tell you that
somebody's a junior what's your updated
belief that they have roommates
you can solve this from first principles
where we're going to generalize this so
we can bring it to the world of
probabilistic models but this is where
it starts take a moment talk to the
person next to you see if you can figure
out what's the probability that somebody
is in a roommate situation given they're
a junior and then we'll see if we can
write this in here
foreign
thank you
this is
oh man what do we do here
okay
you know it you might see this and think
what these are conditional probabilities
in the world of random variables I've
only seen conditional probabilities in
the world of events but in fact this is
an event this is the event where the
roommate situation is that you have
roommates or their housing situation
that you have roommates and this is the
event where your year in school is a
junior and if you think of these as
events
you can do any of the conditional
probability work that you've learned in
this class and really when you have
conditional probability there's two ways
you can approach it you can just think
about the definition of conditional
probability or you can use
base there man that thing that shows up
like a billion times cs109 and cs19 can
be renamed to be like the class we use
base theorem like every third problem
because it's that useful
Bayes theorem would say that you know
this probability
well actually I suppose
wait I I have to forgive myself this is
a situation where actually the
definition of conditional probability is
just fine
oops okay what is the definition of
conditional probability
it says that this is equal to these two
events together
so I'm just do R equals little r for
roommates
or I'll say room for roommates and Y
equals Junior
embarrassing I said base theorem but I
actually meant the definition
probability like forgive myself tonight
and this is it
so it would say that the probability of
this happening is the probability of
them both happening at the same time
divided by just the overall probability
of somebody's a junior not taking into
account what room they're in
so what's the probability of these two
things happening at the same time
roommates and they're a junior
yeah it's 0.04 you know the joint
probability table gives you the
probability of the and of any
combination of random variables
and now you're wondering do I actually
have the probability that somebody's a
junior
yeah that's the marginal it's this is
0.175 and so oh nicely done Google
filling that in for me it tells me that
the probability that somebody is a
junior or that their roommate situation
given that they're a junior is 0.227
wait
given year yeah yeah I got that right
okay
now if we want to know the probably
something's in a two room double given
that they're a junior
what is this going to look like now it's
going to be the same thing just rooms
gonna be two room double
so probably somebody's a two room double
given that they're a junior is going to
be that fraction the probably that
somebody is a a shared partner given
that they're in a tour I guess shared
Partners like you live with a couple
situation uh and nobody reported that
Anonymous survey
um but a lot of people have singles
so you know if you look at the overall
distribution the belief in what room
situations people have very few people
have singles but if you condition on the
fact that people are Juniors it
increases by quite a lot if I sum up all
of these things
stop being trying to be so intelligent
it all gives me one
so that's the probability that
somebody's roommate given their junior
plus it's probably somebody's two room
double given that they're a junior
plus probably a shared partner given
junior plus probably a single given
Junior all of that adds up to one
because these four rooms span the space
so if you enter the world where
somebody's a junior they live in one of
these four living situations
now let's do the same thing with
freshmen but this in this time instead
of using the module I'm going to do
something slightly different I'm still
calculating the same probability so that
probably somebody's a freshman and has
roommates but in this time instead of
using the module I'm going to use the
definition of marginal which is the sum
of this row
and this is
the law of total probability it is
expanding this using the law of tour
probably it's like Junior and or sorry
freshmen and roommates plus freshmen and
two room Doubles Plus freshmen and
shared Partners plus freshman signal and
that's what the Loft total probability
is saying that's where the marginal
comes from
um anyways and so you could fill in this
whole table
to do so that equals this divided by
that number this equals that divided by
this number
and single equals this divided by
so this is very interesting if you think
about the probability Mass function over
rooms
if you don't condition on what your
people are this is what the probability
Mass function says for any assignment to
Rooms it gives you a probability if you
condition on them being a Freshman it
changes if you condition on them being a
junior it changes and that's such a
simple way of communicating what
inferences when you tell me some
information like what your somebody is
you watch the whole probability
distribution of another random variable
change
I think this is easier to see as a chart
okay
here is the idea as our chart this is
the probability distribution of rooms if
you didn't tell me what year somebody
was in cs109 most people have roommates
some people have singles this is a whole
probably Mass function do you guys buy
that
now we infer now we we observe that
somebody's a junior and we infer a whole
new probability Mass function the
probability Mass function changes quite
a lot all of these likelihoods change
once you tell me they're a junior and
look probably if somebody being a single
skyrockets people are much more likely
to have a single in their junior year of
college
and that's a simple idea we're going to
do this we're going to do it for more
and more interesting models we're going
to take a belief in a random variable
we're going to observe some information
we're going to watch the belief in that
random variable change
and sometimes we'll use the definition
of conditional probability and sometimes
equals Bayes theorem to solve for that
okay
just for a little
bunch of these data sets for cs109 and I
can show you how these distributions
change over time here I'm showing you
those distributions changing as people
go from freshmen to sophomores to
Juniors to seniors look what happens to
roommates yeah we're a lot less likely
to have roommates you're more likely to
be in a single room as a junior than as
a five plus which seems a little unfair
that's one data set here's another one
that I collected one year
um this is how people get to class and
you can imagine a lot of people bike to
class especially sophomores all about
the Eco travel uh but then you know
seniors are all about like I don't I've
got so much time to ponder the
complexities of life that I'm just gonna
walk
uh this one's very noisy but this is
where people were eating as you
conditioned on different years of
Stanford so if you condition on somebody
being a sophomore they're very likely
eating a dining hall but like grad
students are like I'm never touching
that food well not never but less likely
um eating clubs might not exist anymore
we used to like be friends and eat
together and like smog is what time is
Wild free pandemic uh and then people
are more likely to make their own food
over time
uh and then you know we had that data
set the other uh day in class and you
can see like what's this relationship
status over a year a year and you can
see like uh people are really don't
couple up but then all of a sudden like
senior year comes and they're like I'm
out of time or something I don't know
laughs
okay also for a little of levity because
you guys are learning some complicated
stuff I very much appreciate that
let's play a little game
little game is called number or function
so if I have two random variables X and
Y and if I ask a question what's
probably x equals two given that y
equals five is that a number or function
think about it think about it think
about it now yell it out loud
yay cool game
okay ooh here's one what's probably the
X takes on the value little x given that
y takes on the value 2.
yeah it's a function and also it's a
random variable it's saying like what is
the probability Mass function of my
random variable in the world where I
observe this thing about another random
variable and that probably Mass function
is a function you can represent as a 1D
table you can represent it as a python
function but it is a function okay very
good okay think about it
think about it think about it yell it
out loud
oh but what it's a 2d function where you
put in both the thing you're
conditioning on and the outcome those
are the two imposes of function uh and
it gives you back a number and in fact
if we went back here if we filled this
whole thing in this is what a 2d
function looks like for any assignment
to roommates in frosh it can produce a
number
okay let's take our pedagogical pause
have two minutes think about life and we
will come back to this idea of inference
that will take it up a notch okay take
two minutes
is
foreign
thank you
so fatherhood's this like exciting
experience
and one of the exciting experiences like
you get to Define like what the universe
looks like to another human being it's a
totally Wild Thing and mostly I've just
been like giving her the honest like
this is what the world is like
um except for I'm trying to convince her
that when people ask you how are you you
just say groovy or feeling groovy like
that's the appropriate response I'm
trying to like not tell her about like
oh I'm good I'm happy it's just always
groovy which is not that important I
hope you guys though are feeling groovy
after that pedagogy
Okay so
Bayes theorem Revisited you know you've
seen this before we've just used it to
figure out who wrote that particular
document and I just want to write it out
again and I want to take a moment to
name the terms
so if you have Bayes theorem there are
names to each of these terms notice how
this term in this term both have the
probability of B
and I really think about beta's theorem
as taking a prior belief and calculating
what we call an updated belief or if
you're really fancy a posterior belief
so this is the belief before you see the
evidence and this is the belief after
you saw the evidence and I really think
of Bayes theorem as a function that
takes a belief and updates it using
evidence
it has these two other terms you have to
know How likely is the evidence given a
particular assignment to the belief
and it has this other term that we now
know to dread the normalization constant
and normalization constant is a pretty
boring name compared to these other
three like posterior likelihood of
evidence probably all very semantic
normalization constants not and we
really do think about this is just
something that we need to calculate if
we want to get our probability
so now we have names for those things
what a nice thing and I just want to
remind us of what we've stated but I
just want to say it again Bayes theorem
with random variables works just like
you imagine it's the exact same thing as
events in this case our events are just
going to be assignments to random
variables
so this is the event where let's say m
is discrete random variable this is an
event where and a discrete random
variable takes on the value of three and
Bayes theorem if you just treat this as
e and this is f you just get plugged
right into your base theorem formula
question
not at all
about base theorem is that I think
there's two ways of doing it I think
last time we did it with the table as
the probability of something and
something over the probability of the
second thing happening and there's this
other option and I don't often know
which one is choose yes so it's a good
point
in the last problem
there's a couple ways of expressing this
numerator and a couple ways of
expressing this denominator
in this last problem you know what I did
is I actually in this numerator had e
and b instead of doing e given B times
probably B I just had probably e comma B
that if you wrote it out like that
technically it would be the definition
of conditional probability so you could
instead of writing that top term or
calculating that top term you could have
calculated this
that's the likelihood of both the events
happening at the same time or if you're
in the world of random variables what we
call The Joint probability of those two
assignments
there's two ways of thinking about this
just like we have one formula that's
just this over that and another formula
which is this over that
obviously that makes those two things
equal and actually if you thought about
the chain rule the chain rule says that
this times this equals that so if you
take what's the likelihood of B to
happen what's likelihood of e given B
you multiply those two things together
you get a chance of e and B happening so
you have that option yes
exclusively play into that do you have
to choose one if the events
no it doesn't matter neither
Independence nor Mutual exclusivity
matters these apply to any pairs of
events for any two pairs of events Bayes
rule applies and you can use either it
just has to with information was given
to you like in the last problem the
table had this information so this was a
convenient form in the Hamilton problem
we didn't have this but we have the
condition like probability of words
given the author and then we had a
belief about the author so we were given
information in these two expressions
yes
yeah yeah no this is the point yes so
that that means the joint probability of
e and B is
uh the numerator of the guys say like
when you have a given B
given me now so e given B uh and what
was so um
yes
exactly exactly so if you multiply the
probability of evidence with your prior
you get the joint probability of the
prior and the evidence together exactly
what a nice way of putting it
okay
so we're bumping this up and it's not
too big a leap but I don't want to lose
anybody on this leap when we go to the
world of random variables it's the same
Bayes theorem it's just our events are
made with assignments to random
variables if I give you a concrete
statement like this I think a lot of
people follow me I think where I could
lose a lot of people is when I change it
to something like this
where instead of writing concrete
numbers with events we can imagine I use
symbols so like the probably that M
takes on the value Little M and the
probably n takes on the value little n
and I just put in a variable assignment
this is true it's just using a lot more
symbols in its notation so it's the
exact same thing these are all events
I'm just trying to write a bunch of
statements with concrete numbers all in
one expression
so whenever you see something like this
feel free to slow me down and be like
whoa whoa Chris what do you mean when
you say probably the M takes on the
value Little M
okay
and I want to remind us of the shorthand
I talked about at the beginning of class
this becomes very clunky to write and a
lot of times you'll see things like this
so probably of Little M given n implies
this bigger expression so it implies
there is a random variable with the
capital taking on this value there's a
random variable with capital N taking on
this value but just it's so much easier
to write and almost easier to see that
people love this notation so if you read
a paper you'll almost always see this
shorthand notation
okay
let's try a real problem
so when babies are born they can't tell
you whether or not they hear things so
they do this test to see whether or not
babies can hear where they'll play a
sound and then they'll watch if babies
actually change their gaze and it is a
totally uh stochastic experience
sometimes babies just look different
directions for unrelated reasons and
there has to be a lot of reasoning under
uncertainty to try and infer is this
baby hearing given how they change their
gaze so I'm going to give you
a lot of information about a joint
relationship of two random variables the
two random variables that are
interesting here are whether or not the
baby changes their gaze and how much
they do so it's a random variable which
can take on values and there's another
random variable and this one is going to
be Bernoulli it's either true or false
and it's whether or not the baby can
hear the sound I'm going to call that
one y
equals one
just so we can enter the world of using
random variables
so we're going to observe x equals zero
and we want to calculate what's the
probability of Y equaling 1 given that x
equals zero
now interestingly here the information I
give you is a conditional probability
table here I give you the probability of
x given that y equals one that's this
column and here's the probability of x
given that y equals zero
in order to solve any conditional
probability question you want to have
the joint distribution but you want to
know something crazy I've actually given
you the joint because of giving you the
probably equals y equals one I've given
you the probably y equals zero that's
just one over four and then the
probability of x given y if you multiply
the probability of x given y times
probably of Y you've got the joint but
that's not that important right now what
is important right now is I'm going to
want to calculate the probability of y
equals one
um so that the baby can hear the sound
given that x equals zero
and take a moment with that person next
to you see if you can figure out how
we're going to get probably of y equals
one given x equals zero with the
information that we've got and so this
is a way to practice what we've been
talking about with Bayes theorem
I think
divide by probability of patent
thank you
okay
it's asking a conditional probability
question
so we've talked about how that's often
going to give you an expression that
looks like this
at the top you might have this product
of two different probabilities the prior
and the likelihood of the evidence given
the belief
or if you're given different information
this might be as better to represent
just using the joint probability of x
equals zero and Y equals one two options
there
but the problem really pushes you
towards one of them and the reason the
problem pushes you towards one is that
we are given x given y equals one and x
given y equals zero
so we're given X in the context where y
equals one that's the left hand side and
we've got x square y equals zero so
because the information is given to us
in this format it's a nice place to
start
so what's the probability x equals zero
given y equals one this seems like
something we could just look up
0.08
it's that top thing in the row it says
you know if y equals one probably x
equals zero is just this number what is
the probability that y equals one your
belief before you walk into the
experiment
yeah 0.75 and you know that hopefully
came from some informed belief uh and
somebody didn't just make up that number
though
there's this whole debate and
probability about like some people this
just like turns some people in the
mathematical worlds insane because
they're like how did you get that prior
and people get like really up in arms
about it but that's not important right
now what is important is this
normalization constant
what are we going to do with this
normalization constant question
it's actually a different number
if you add up this column you should get
one if I did everything right
four five six seven yeah I think eight
nine ten this all adds up to one and
that makes sense because if you enter
the world where the baby can hear
then you should see one of these values
if you enter the world where the baby
can't hear you should see one of these
values you get a full probability Mass
function
so it's a good question so this doesn't
keep any information about the prior the
prior has to be given externally
yeah yeah but if it was a joint the
probability of the prior would have been
inside of it
so this is not a joint table this is a
conditional probability table so we
don't we're given the probably one
random variable condition on the other
like it's
when we go back here remember there's
these two tables this is the joint table
and then we start calculating this
conditional table
we've been given a conditional table
here
okay somebody help us what are we going
to do about this normalization constant
just forget about it we can calculate
the probability of
y equals zero given x equals zero and
then try and divide it we could do that
but we don't need to do that here there
is an easier way
yes law of total probability wow to the
probability but what
you know we've kind of got this classic
probability that x equals zero given y
equals one times the probability that y
equals one plus the probability that x
equals zero given y equals zero times
the probability that y equals zero
you know if you just thought of these as
the world of events this is your classic
version of Base that you've used a whole
bunch in your homework and then again we
know this term .08 we know this term
0.75 we know this term it's 0.25 and
probably the Y equals zero x equals zero
given that y equals zero is just 0.4
and this would just become you know 0.4
times 0.25 and this would be a 0.08
times 0.75 and we have numbers for every
term so we could just calculate it
um
here it is written up into slides you
know we just wanted to do basically a
straight base and the challenge of this
problem was mostly just understanding
that information was given to you as
this conditional probability table so we
have a whole random variable in the
world where y equals one and a whole
random variable in the world where y
equals zero with once you realize what
information you've got you just plug it
in chug and you get your updated belief
of three over eight that the baby can
hear and that's quite interesting you
know like
you saw an experiment and gave you
results and the results might have just
LED somebody to conclude that the baby
can't hear because they didn't respond
but because there's so much noise in
this experiment there's so much
stochasticity to how babies respond
you're actually not that confident after
you've adjusting one observation
question
and so let's say you instead observed x
equals five how would you know if you
were supposed to use the confidence in
the first row oh yeah this is a little
bit poorly defined you know hopefully
somebody tells you if this is like
inclusive or exclusive very good
question so like so hopefully somebody
did a better job of writing this table
but also you'll never see exactly five
it'll be like four point nine nine nine
nine nine or five point zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero one or larger
but that's such a cop-out answer good
question okay yes
to range from 0
from 0 to that
uh yeah this is interesting you know
technically this probably should be a
continuous random variable and we'll get
to that later I'll have a continuous
version of this but here I did kind of a
hacky discretization I took my
continuous space and I bend it
um and people do that and normally when
it's been you just treat everything and
Bin as one
okay good question
you guys one last thing I want us to do
I want us to mix some discrete and
continuous
I have a super interesting problem
that's going to make us think about
continuous random variables
it kind of speaks to the question that
was just asked what would you do if this
wasn't discrete random variable how
would you treat it if your random
variable was say a gaussian
so without trying to gender elephants
I'm going to do this problem
it turns out that girl Elephants or
female elephants and male elephants at
Birth have different distributions of
weights and these are actually real
distributions so uh male female
elephants are 160 kilograms with this
standard deviation and male elephants
are 165 kilograms well heavy with this
standard deviation
and just to practice this is not the
most interesting problem but I thought
it was one that could help us practice
updating a continuous belief given
information
all right sorry updating a belief given
continuous information
here we want to say all you know about a
newborn elephant is its weight you're
told that's a 163 kilograms
and now I want you to change your belief
about whether or not it's a boy or a
girl
your prior belief is that it's one half
one half but your posterior belief will
be something different and it's going to
require us to think about the world of
discrete random variables and continuous
together
let me just Define some things that are
said in this problem
there's two random variables G is going
to be about whether or not the elephant
is a girl and G is a Bernoulli with
probability 0.5 it's one half
probability prior
X is the distribution the weight of the
elephants
if you tell me g equals one I know X is
this normal distribution if you tell me
g equals zero I know X is this
distribution
and
you know maybe you take this and you
start writing out
your Bayes theorem you're like this
problem says I want to know the
probability of g equals one or G one for
girl given that x equals 163. and you
got probability of g equals one
given x equals 163. and it seems so
straightforward it seems like
everything's going to be just fine and I
promise it'll be just fine
um
so you've got probably x equals 163
given that g equals one times the
probability that g equals one
divided by the probability that x equals
163.
and you can you know figure out that
normalization constant
this feels fine
until you get to this expression
if I tell you
that an elephant is a female what's the
probability that its weight is exactly
163.
zero because for continuous random
variables we think about
163.000
with infinite precision as being an
event that never happens and so it
started as a simple problem now seems
terrifying
but let me give you an aside that's
going to make this not so terrifying
um sorry we have joint distributions we
have this goal of inference remember at
the beginning of class I gave us this
insight
sure for a continuous random variable
the probability that takes on a value is
zero but a calculus way of interpreting
that zero is it is the density so the
derivative times an Epsilon since that
Epsilon is basically zero you can think
of this as zero or the calculus way
allows you to add in an Epsilon
what that means is instead of having
this probability here I can put in an
Epsilon
not times the probability but times the
probability density
and this seems fine but then you get an
answer with an Epsilon in it what the
hell does that mean
until
you don't give up and you get to this
part and you're like this probability
it's the probability that elephant is
exactly 163. again you have a continuous
random variable
and again you have something that should
be a zero and we're dividing by zero
naughty us
but again you're like this probability
we can represent it as an Epsilon times
the density
to put that more precisely let's say you
have a discrete and a continuous random
variable
this continuous random variable
probability of an exact assignment can
be thought of as density times Epsilon
and you have an exact assignment on both
the numerator and the denominator and
then a beautiful beautiful thing happens
when you write it out like this your
epsilon's cancel and a little tear comes
to your eye because you're like I didn't
know what to do with those epsilons but
they just went away I wish every problem
in life could be that easy
and when they just go away you're left
with this new version of bass you guys
now have a brand new version of babes
welcome to the class new version of Base
it looks just like your Bayes theorem
but whenever you have a continuous
random variable on the left side instead
of using the probability Mass function
you're using the probability density
function
and this is the missing information that
we needed in order to solve our elephant
problem
so there's a bunch of versions of Bays
where you mix discrete and continuous
but the long story short is in all of
them anytime you have a continuous on
the left use probably density
um and so here you know if you have a
continuous random variable my X and y's
are continuous you use density anytime
you have continuous use density every
time you have discrete you use the
probability Mass function and it all
works out because of those Epsilon
canceling so you can derive each of
these independently
okay
going back to my elephant
I want to think about this again so
these epsilons are gone life seems
pretty good
but we still need to solve the problem
and we're not done
the first thing I want to think about is
how do you want to expand this lower
term and I'm going to say we can use the
law of total probability and actually
the slide in the aside that I skipped is
the law of total probability also has
this function where you know if n is
discrete and X is continuous then you
can just use the probability density in
place of the probability and again you
could use an Epsilon to derive this if
you wanted to
so here
this is equal to
the probability density
times your prior
divided by we have to expand this term
and I'm going to use the law of total
probability so f of x equals 163 given
that g equals 1 times the probability g
equals one
plus the density of 163 given g equals
zero so it's a boy times the prior
probability that g equals zero
and here you have just your standard
base it's just any time you had a
continuous random variable use density
instead of probabilities
okay what's the probability that g
equals one
one-half yeah so this is just going to
be one half this is one half and this is
one-half all those terms cancel out
and we're just left with these three
terms and you're like oh great three
simple terms what are we going to do
what is this is the probability density
at 163 in the world where the gender is
female
well in the world where gender is female
X is given by this normal distribution
and if this is the normal distribution
what's the probability density at 163
if only we had a probability density
formula
which we do have we have a probability
density formula we know the like
tribution taking on a particular value
so if this normal distribution has a
particular mean in particular variance
which we know we can ask what's the
likelihood of it taking on value 163
we're just going to be plugging in that
bad boy in for this or a girl because g
equals one putting it over there for
this one and then here it's the same
thing it's just we've got the
distribution for whether or not it's a
male and so the probability density
function of the normal comes in to save
the day I appreciate this is a very hard
thing to do you guys worked very hard to
follow a lot of complicated ideas
but the power that it will lead to is
worth it it's going to allow us to solve
very interesting problems if you can
Master the skill of inference we
practice on some shorter problems we're
going to finish our practice but I have
a sweet promise for you guys on Monday
come back on Monday we're going to use
this exact same mathematics not to solve
a toy problem but to solve a real
problem as you guys know the Stanford
Acuity with test was invented here in
cs109 it does an eye test where you keep
track of your belief distribution of
what a person can see and it keeps
updating with new evidence it's the
world's most accurate eye test and we
will take this math and we'll make
something real come back on Monday have
a fantastic weekend see you guys cs109
sorry for all the yelling